ce sont les dernières images de
micheline myrtil celle d'un chanter noël
quelques jours avant son décès
inexpliqué aux urgences de l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris depuis une semaine
sa famille au vauclin et plongé dans
l'incertitude
ce travail me demande mais de quel à
kessel a eu je me dis qu'elle est soit
moins qu'elle a souffert elle a souffert
beaucoup fait des beaucoup d'idées le 17
décembre
micheline myrtille les transférer sur
ans de son médecin aux urgences de
l'hôpital lariboisière
elle souffre de maux de tête d'une forte
fièvre le lendemain matin elle est
retrouvée morte sur son brancard au
téléphone sa fille
sur place elle tente d'obtenir des
réponses une autopsie a bien été
pratiquée mais les résultats n'ont pas
encore été communiquées à la famille et
oui une famille tout entière plongé dans
le doute qui peut compter sur le soutien
d'amis et de voisins
ça m'a fait un choc d un que si cette
personne est restée 12 heures sur vingt
quatre
et quand j'étais élève en ce1 moment
était malade j'avais un piège à l'esa
point m'est arrivé aussi quelque chose
comme ça la famille rencontrée
aujourd'hui la direction de l'hôpital à
paris une famille qui vit dans la tente
de réponse pour pouvoir enfin rapatrier
le corps est enterré micheline ici chez
elle en martinique